[Music]
foreign
live from Edinburgh a first look at
what's on the front pages as they arrive
and it's time to see what's making the
headlines I've got with me the political
reporter with the national Abbey Garden
Crosby and the political editor of the
Scottish son Rachel Watson very welcome
all of you well let's see then what's on
some of those front pages for you
and starting with the Scotsman well uh
it's dominated all the papers are with
an image of Nicholas sturgeon this one
peeking out of a window on the day that
the first Minister announced that she
was stepping down
the financial times describes the
Scottish national party as being at the
crossroads after Nicholas sturgeon's
resignation as Scotland's first minister
the eye has this headline Independence
dream Fades as sturgeon quits
the national quotes from her departure
speech earlier today saying it's been
the privilege of my life while
the Metro writes a political obituary
for both Nicholas sturgeon and Jeremy
corbyn he's been banned from standing as
a labor candidate at the next general
election by secure Starman and then in
other news the mirror reports on new
developments in the case of the missing
mother of two Nicola bully
as does the express its headline high
risk Nicola had issues with alcohol
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code that's on the screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us discussing them all and as I
say join tonight by Abby Garten Crosby
and Rachel Watson well now uh let's go
through well I mean first of all before
we look at that maybe it's been such a
momentous day it's been so unexpected I
suppose certainly in terms of the timing
and perhaps slightly in terms of the the
manner of the delivery and the and the
personal nature of that resignation
statement by Nicholas sturgeon so let's
start with the I which talks about the
independent stream fading as sturgeon
quits and uh Rachel I mean you know
that's the prime directive of the SNP
that's uh lifelong political ambition
and and it didn't happen yeah and that's
obviously where attention will go to in
the immediate point of Nicola sturgeon's
resignation we know that this was a big
moment for the first Minister following
the supreme court judgment last year
that she could not you know laterally
hold a referendum and call one in
Scotland by herself so she looked to
this other reason other way forward that
she felt wasn't perfect but might help
get to that point which was the de facto
referendum using the next general
election as a referendum as a vote on
Independence but that wasn't popular and
there was polling at the weekend that
showed just 21 of Voters in Scotland
back this idea there's also been the
senior figures within her party
including MPS such as Stuart McDonald
who have raised issues with this they
weren't happy with this and didn't
believe this was the right way to go
they felt building momentum for the
cause and I think we're just weeks away
from this special conference that the
SNP were planning to hold and discuss
this option and Nicholas surgeon cited
this in Her speech today that she felt
leaving before this conference would
give the SMP space to discuss it and I
think this is one of the the key reasons
you know she didn't really want to go
there and see what the key reasons were
for her leaving rather that it was you
know it was the time she felt the
pressure and or she wanted to kind of
take me start making those moves away
from politics but you know speak to
anybody and they will see that the fact
that she was finding it difficult to
move on with the independence cause and
gain support not only with the public
but her own party will be a key reason
for her decision today I'll be your take
on that I mean Independence seems to
have gone a bit further away rather than
got closer well Nicholas sturgeon
although she has been the face of the
independence movement for the past eight
years isn't the only person involved in
the independence movement and it is much
bigger than one person I don't think
that her resignation means the dream is
dead but I do think it signals a new era
of the SNP of the party and of the you
know it needs a bit of New Blood to come
in and they need to establish what the
plan is going forward is it going to be
the factory referendum is there another
plan and she's obviously made it clear
that she doesn't have the energy to do
so much to handle but in terms of her
political Legacy we've all been talking
about how long was she's being politics
and how young she was when she started
when she was starting back then you know
when she imagined her stepping away from
Politics as much as she is it would have
been having delivered in Triumph an
independent nation of course that would
have been her ideal situation but the
Supreme Court ruling put a massive block
in the way of that and there's no really
the UK government isn't going to give a
section 30 order then we're stuck a rock
in a hard place right now between people
who want an independent referendum and
the government blocking it so while
Nicholas sturgeon hasn't achieved our
Dream she has achieved a law and she
also has brought Independence to some of
the highest points of share for yes and
polls she has you know changed the
discussion around it the party is a lot
more Progressive now that she's been in
charge there's a lot more feminist
undertones women's health plans things
like that aside from Independence so she
has had a massive impact whether she's
not achieved her top dream she has
achieved a lot I think that that is
well let's talk about the future of the
s p and of course what a success and
whoever that may be does let's have a
look at the financial times uh which
points out as I say they're all on more
or less the same story the s p said a
Crossroads after sturgeon steps aside
our Scotland's first Minister and Rachel
then whoever takes over how do they
carry on that Legacy and that key pledge
about the next general election being a
referendum on Scottish independence do
you think they keep that or they
distance themselves from it it depends
who it is and that's going to be the key
thing with candidates who you know
nobody's come forward yet we know that
there are talk there's talks going on
between a few behind the scenes but
nobody's come forward yet and I think
the key issue here will be what
candidate says what about independence
and how they want to go forward it's
been a huge
um kind of strain on the party in the
past we had talk about a plan B and a
plan C where it didn't look like a
section 30 as Abby said was going to
come from the UK government and allow
that referendum to take place with the
backing of the UK government so I think
what will come next is we will hear a
lot setting out the stall and what
people believe and I think this de facto
plan has had a lot of criticism so I
think candidates coming forward will be
thinking really deeply about whether
this is something that they want to take
forward but as Abby said the party
really is stuck between a rock and a
hard place on this because
what is their way to move the movement
forward how do they now progress the
cause for Independence because there is
no way for them to hold an independence
referendum at the moment and we have you
know do they look towards the de facto
referendum a way to try and maneuver it
forward with that or is it building
support Nicholas surgeon's been someone
who's always been a little bit more
cautious than some in the party would
like she's never spoken about a wildcat
referendum for example she's always held
back and that's gained her criticism
from some quarters if you look at the
former first ministerial examine for
example in his Alba party and and it
will be interesting now to see what
candidates come forward and whether
people say that they would be up for
something like that what kind of
candidate what kind of new leader do
they need Abby in your estimation do
they need somebody to try and unify them
I mean there are quite clearly splits
well certainly divisions within the
party they've been pretty clear over the
last few weeks and Manson does such a
candidate exist well you know later
we're discussing this before we came on
over who do we think could be the next
there are a couple of names up there you
know and obviously The Bookies favorite
to take over but I think it needs
someone who is going to have a very
clear plan of what they want to do they
have a very individual majority of the
party with them if they have a good
enough plan yeah basically I think it
needs to be something different now
something that acknowledges where we are
with the Supreme Court in the section 30
order but also gives a bit of a boost to
the movement because Nicola sturgeon
leaving is is kind of hurt a lot of
people and it's kind of dampen spirit so
it needs to be somebody with energy and
with a plan basically I talked uh before
we started looking at the papers about
just the nature of that news conference
and the the mail gets it it's the
personal side of what we heard this
morning I mean there was an awful lot in
there from Nicola sturgeon which was
more or less saying wasn't it look I'm a
human being I've got feelings this is a
really tough tough job and me you know
don't think it doesn't take its personal
toll the male says you know tearful
sturgeon quits I'm not sure perhaps she
did I'm not sure she actually did tear
up but she kept saying Rachel that she
was very close to it yeah and she did
look at I was in the room this morning
and she did look like she was fighting
back tears at one point especially when
she spoke at the end and she thanked her
family and her husband and I think it is
those personal issues that the first
Minister brought up you know she spoke
about not being able to go for a coffee
and things like that and you know she
admitted nobody's going to get a violin
out for her because you know she has
been first Minister it's been her
decision to stay on for as long as she
has but I think you know everybody knows
staying in a job like that through the
covered pandemic it takes its toll we
had to send out our darn
um who announced her resignation just a
few weeks ago and at that point Nicola
sturgeon said you know I've still got
plenty in the tank I'm not going
anywhere anytime soon but I think those
few weeks she's been reflective on it
and she's realized that actually now is
the time to go and you know it's not
just the independence issue that has
been a problem for Nicholas sturgeon
there's other major issues I'm the
Health Care system for example it was
touched on earlier on Sky about the
attainment Gap there's been issues
around her controversial transgender
reforms and trans prisoners in Scotland
so I think all of this and will have
been huge she said that none of these
had you know been the straw that brought
the camels back it wasn't like she was
leaving for any kind of recent problem
but these things do add up and it has
been a long eight years for Michael
sturgeon Abby why do you think why all
of a sudden I mean it had been discussed
you know we we all knew that she was
thinking about it we all knew that there
were some internal pressures on her as
well but you know 90 90 minutes notice I
think you guys were given right I didn't
mean to get your act together and get to
the news luckily we had somebody ordered
in Edinburgh heading for another press
conference so we managed to send
something but I was in Glasgow and
didn't make it but yeah Nicholas
sturgeon um
I just why all of a sudden you know yeah
I mean you know she couldn't she
apologized for doing it during half term
a week for a start but you know why did
something well do we know did something
break over overnight I don't know I
think from my perspective she's chosen a
good time to go there was a dip in her
popularity ratings obviously in a
previous poll that showed you know our
popularity was going down but she was
still one of the most popular leaders
compared to kirst armor and a sarbar
Richie sinach and Douglas she was way
ahead of them so I think she's taken
perhaps been adverse but a little bit of
a leaf out of Alex Salmon's book to go
when you know everything's all right
there's no scandals there's nothing
really big pressing and she's taking the
decision on her own foot and she's made
this on her terms which is why I think
she's done it that way and just about
those she mentioned Abby mentions there
Rachel you know the other parties is
this a bit of a political opportunity of
course for labor for to claw back some
of those losses over the years yeah I
think Libra will definitely be the
happiest party about today's
announcement in Scotland they have their
Scottish conference they this week I am
wearing a star morning curious armor
expected to give their keynote speeches
to the membership up here and there was
already a feeling within the labor party
that they were on the rise that they
were on the march in Scotland to gain
back some of those voters they'd lost
and this does really present them with
that opportunity because for the last
couple of years Nicholas sturgeon we
touched on her
um opinion ratings have been higher you
know she got through the covert Pandemic
those
um those briefings that she had the
other parties felt she really benefited
from that and that she'd gained through
her communication skills and I think
they will now be looking to say well you
know nobody else in the smps as good a
communicator they'll be looking and
thinking nobody else is really as good
as it as she will be and she did enjoy
I'm going to let you we've got a minute
left uh Abby look at the national your
paper it's been the privilege of my life
I mean there are moments we've talked
about you know the hard yard she did but
I remember doing the 2019 general
election when we saw the picture of her
celebrating when the lib Dam leader last
night
I was hiding behind the cameras and that
happened actually yeah I mean Nicholas
Sergeant she has had a lot of she's
achieved a lot of things you know she's
done very well and I think she leaves
the movement with a lot to think on you
know she's been a really big figure in
Independence Movement that's why we've
chosen that front state today it
signifies who she is and what she's done
for not just the s p but the wider
movement too and I think that she'll go
down in history further it has she been
too big a figure in terms of that
successor we're talking about I mean
they're awfully big boots to fill oh
there's nothing wrong with a bit of
fresh blood ever so often
okay well Avi Rachel thank you very much
indeed for the time being we're going to
a short break and coming up as a two
decade chapter of Nicola sturgeon's
career comes to an end we'll look back
on some of the key moments we've been
mentioning some of them already along
the way that's after the break
[Music]
thank you
are watching The Press preview with me
now have you gotten Crosby and Rachel
Watson we are discussing the front page
of the papers which are all of course
reacting to Nicola sturgeon's
resignation uh dramatic news conference
today ending our time as first minister
of Scotland after eight years and uh
Abby you want to look at your paper
again the national has inside it pages
eight nine the key moments during
Nicholas sturgeon's time as first
Minister some of her Greatest Hits so to
speak um 58 high water marker in the
polls of people who wanted independence
of course they're handling of the covid
Pandemic those regular daily uh for
quite a while press conferences cop 26
um well let's mention that you know um
doesn't seem that very long ago but
Scotland of course hosted got 26 but
made quite an impact as well on on
global politics yeah Nicholas sturgeon
was um very popular at Croc 26 I know
that they weren't part part of the UK
negotiations but you know Nicholas
sturgeon was the leader of the host
country because it's in Glasgow and I
remember being there and I remember one
of the standard moments from that which
obviously is not about the climate but
she gave um AOC a kind of iron Brew
which went quite viral because obviously
she's an American politician never tried
it and things like that she's also given
the ray of the day award because in
Scotland where it's the first country in
the world to put a million pounds into a
fund for loss and damage and then she
doubled that so she's given an awards
and you know that loss and damage thing
at cop27 and that became the main kind
of feature of that club so that had a
massive impact going into the next one
in Egypt and and more more countries
starting to put money into the fund so
she had an impact on that too and I
think you know that's something that
really should be considered she really
has championed loss and damage for you
know countries in the global size it's
been impacted by the climate and you
know the wealthy countries should pay up
for the damage that they've caused which
I think is a pretty good record to have
Rachel what would you pick out of that
list I mentioned there also um the
policy here of baby boxes just explain
that yes or she mentioned baby boxes in
Her speech today is something she was
proud of these are boxes that are given
to new parents parents to be ahead of
their baby's arrival and they have a
number of things in them
um baby girls thermometers other things
that are needed and it has been one of
the things that has been a success for
the SMP and the Scottish government
um but you know again
um as she faced many questions at her
press conference as we mentioned on the
show today there are obviously things
that nickel surgeon will want to talk
about and people in the party will want
to be reflective on
um at this time but at the same time she
is still first Minister she still has a
job to do before she steps down that
includes you know today teachers
rejected the latest pay deal and from
the Scottish government so we know
skills are going to um teachers are
going to go on strike again and schools
will close and the NHS still facing huge
pressure and needs the help and support
the Scottish government and other
questions that the first minister is
facing on a huge a whole range of policy
at the moment that she might not be too
proud of as well as she steps away yeah
I mean that's the point isn't it Abby
the um her opponents want to point out
those issues and they are particularly
highlight the domestic agenda the bread
and butter agenda and you know
Independence yes your ultimate goal but
what about our day-to-day lives well I
guess from the SNP Independence is part
of the data vehicle because all these
things come into Independence you know
the reason that we are having issues
with the teacher funding and pay deals
is that there's a set Barnet formula and
the s p government didn't raise the
income tax at the last budget to bring
in more income so we're stuck with the
same amount of money that we can have
whereas you know as the SMP would say if
we have Independence then we can base
our own funds we can decide what we do
with our own thing so yes the day job
has to be dealt with by whoever comes in
next and but I don't think Independence
is going to fall off the agenda okay
we're nearly out of time we're going to
have a look at one more of the front
pages I think foreign
writers and you two as newspaper people
can um I congratulate the sub editors or
not we've got the Metro which has uh
looked at two major politicians in the
UK today um having uh different ends to
their careers or is it and there we are
sturt gone yeah very good and core Bend
well let's talk about the core Bend bit
because I say you know well Nicola
sturgeon has gone of her own volition
Jeremy corbyn has been told to go been
banned by the labor party for a while
their secure storm has told him today
that he's not going to be able to stand
for his beloved Islington North seat but
the question is Rachel I suppose will he
stand as an independent to I know it's
not in Scotland but will he stands as an
independent and um you know could he
split the labor vote there I mean it's a
huge day for politics and as you said
the Metro have made full use of that in
their front page today and you have to
congratulate some vegetarians when they
managed to pull those things off it's a
perfect day for it exactly well that is
true um to be nice to the subs but I
think
um you know this will be a question as
many people have said today Jeremy
corbyn is considering whether he stands
as an independent and he's obviously not
happy at the fact that he cannot stand
for labor will he therefore look to
split that labor vote and upset
kiersteiner and the new labor leadership
because of the way that he feels he's
been treated by the party and I think
you know kirst armor obviously had to
make a decision on this and you know to
win back that labor vote and try and and
entice people in other areas back to his
party I'm sorry we're out of time but uh
let's hear it for those sub-editors
Rachel Watson Abby Garten Crosby very
good to see but thank you very much
indeed for helping us talk through all
those papers